o local deveria ter votado não é legal e
vai sobre o gol
os dois não venho aqui com o palanque e
confesso que foi difícil e leva o
coração desta vez sozinho de plantão ao
vivo é porque o primeiro não vou falar
não faço eu vou falar desde então poderá
ser invertido ou não de vida
para tal comoviam deixar melhores coisas
que vão pensar nas coisas difícil eo
shin nome da mãe é dizer que se você
quiser escolher sem mundo
tô agora o senhor agora já me sinto
assim uma coisa especial
o bom é que eu ia fazer diferença por
onde passamos e facto não é fácil falar
nós ao controle do conteúdo da norma
aula e falamos de um assunto que sabemos
bastante e aqui não não é assim
vamos tentar explicar como é que foi
minha vida como é que cheguei à
profissão que tem o santo andré mas
claramente não é minha praia não é
descobrir a forma clássica diz a ser
membro do corpo
depois pensei muito um dos animais e eu
adoro animais mas é difícil ter tantos
animais sofram as coisas para minha mãe
mas faço isso também com os meus filhos
passa a virar sexta-feira em sua fé é
uma profissão que ainda hoje vou
gratuito mas vou fazendo isto montanhas
remotas fio a pavio no entanto não foi
por aí que minha mãe não ficou contente
surfista é que começaram em relação com
o mar dos açores e o céu foi uma coisa
que está em salvador e que faça algumas
sessões dos 16 aos 20 anos foi assaltado
nas praias da costa da caparica e aí
ouvi algumas pessoas com fáceis
de fato hoje estão vivas que nós
estávamos lá e aqui
acredito que para aquelas pessoas
aquelas famílias
claramente a diferença embora não faça
isso o jogador
andava sempre com os olhos na cabeça é o
fundo mar era fantástico no sul da china
é igualmente fantástica e portanto
naquela cidade mas ainda hoje claramente
aquela profissão quer como investigador
que mergulho com escafandro button quer
como em apneia que faz com alguma
comunidade
bom depois numa aventura que aventura
toda estava no 12º ano e como sou uma
pessoa muito educada e não sabia onde
queria ir
e então uma pessoa aquelas pessoas que
fazem diferença na vida de uma pessoa
a cidade de seu nome inclusive o 12º
disco miguel nasceu em 1811 marinha a
marinha assim um novo lugar de praia
neymar também foi primeiro lugar em
engenharia mecânica por causa das motas
e arquitetura
efe
uma série de atividades como dirigente
objetivos fiz o polivalente no primeiro
pau e vôlei da escola foi feito nessa
altura percebi que queria ir pra fora
[Música]
gostava de trabalhar com tubarões cria
também a controlar e estou tranquila
quando disse que recebeu a bola e também
faz entrega quase certa depois diz que
está tudo mais o que então passou-se no
grupo de pessoas foi objetivo eu não sei
se eu quero um xodó rubro taurina no
topo da fotografia love trabalhar com o
irmão não será amanhã em fio
esse dinheiro e então também nessa
altura quando estava a região em preto
fantástico não estava incluso e quinta
do lago
minha função era simples era servido vim
ajudar os colegas da sala e técnicos em
outra coisa por ela quer ir vai comer e
então disseram olha a mata da sala
como deixei a taxa tem mais a nota da
cozinha em 26 de maio a cheta mas porque
não sabemos tudo na mesma
não é porque a nota fala num não janta
com nota da cozinha eu ela torneio de
nice em rádios vão expirar
vamos pedir comida que vão fazer para
chegar na sala rapidamente temos que
mudar isso
a verdade é que uma semana depois
mudamos aqui e pensarão que faz toda a
pena na mesma fala
curiosamente de vista continua no mesmo
sítio o mesmo chefe e continuam todos a
correr junto a essas refeições também aí
ainda hoje os membros daquele momento em
que quer um cliente depois é em bienne
outra história engraçadas que benny
binion ilha das bananas por conseguir
uma vitória potencia a honestidade miami
e curiosamente um ambiente não fazia
ciência estava lá há tanto tempo
cansados do trabalho estavam todos à
espera confessou grupo vierci uma semana
depois propor um ponto de situação e
para começar a arrancar com novos
projetos
estamos a moto não pode usar o marketing
ou menos ver um esteróide diesel
os barcos são todos favoritos não
tiveram tanta espera do mecânico estavam
a bordo dois tempos
é igual a uma faixa
isto é igual e esse foi um sonho de
montar um tucano estava se esgotando
eu não sei quem é e dos seis barcos que
não funcionavam cinco passarão a
funcionar com coisas muito simples e
quando chegou do doutor bruno diz 'bom
agora vamos ter tarefas novas eu sei que
tem que ter um canil e de lá essa briga
gestora do equipamento é ver né não
os barcos só temos um tornar parar os
outros já estão todas a funcionar é mas
quem é que fez na frança miguel
português a chamar que já sabe
investigar com 70 anos com total apoio
externo principal e foi assim que eu
comecei a trabalhar
não percebi usina e ele perguntou nomes
que sabia rezar também aqui é utilizado
falar assim de se aposentar proveito
depois disto mais outra
outro golpe de sorte ea sorte é uma
coisa que dar muito trabalho
só tem uma coisa que se conquista que
dar mesmo muito trabalho
o oceanário de lisboa a 22 anos naquela
casa foram escolas vida tudo que sair do
treino
tudo isso digo aquela instituição mas
também pela história pascal acionário
foi muito engraçado lá estava e me dá
total dos tubarões com o cabelo até aqui
e no fim vamos lá 1 nas pessoas
voluntárias para aprender sobre os
tubarões e ao fim de uma semana de um
atavismo assim que o destino ao cenário
está 95 98 5 entre inter e talvez nem se
e desejo é que eu sou o dono da empresa
que está a construir
ela então é preciso dar o que falar
inglês e novamente falou em português e
principalmente o melhor para nos ajudar
a construir porque temos a certeza que
fazendo as coisas bem
falo mesmo estava em lisboa é trabalhar
com uma empresa americana que estava com
o atual cenário e depois foi acabei por
ficar não assinarem uma paixão 22 anos
entretanto ao longo desta vida tornou o
cenário 48 vida naquela altura havia
muito muito objetivo
para fazer o tratamento porque é para o
curto os vários cursos para o objetivo
da empresa objetivos de vida
um carlo motos novas aquelas coisas
todas que a gente sonha e uma casa maior
tudo manhã todos esses objetivos
tudo isso usa e muda quando esta é
princesa que está aqui uma nf dia 3 vai
sair da china a casa comprou equipamento
como paradigma paragem respiratória e
vir aí pro os estudos que sentia que o
produto estava em uma festa ela estava
nos trinta e tal pessoas lá em casa
ninguém que o seu silêncio absurdo e foi
assim que surgiu a única pessoa que não
foi meu filho mais velho deles mas não
se preocupe que a empresa vai voltar e
foi aí que eu percebi que tinha que
fazer qualquer coisa me feito o rebanho
espera 3 dólares por dia 0 e triunfo ó
tem de chamar pelo treino tem que fazer
qualquer coisa
hoje em dia 13 e 16 anos uma menina
fantástica sempre os mesmos mas estuda
uma maneira de testar um dos objetivos
da reunião com centrais e bons momentos
tanto os meus filhos do pai da mãe levam
uma formação se tudo correr vai uma
formação superior uma ferramenta para
saber e fazer o que quiserem
passados em estúdio mas os amigos também
têm um papel importante
enormes tem um papel fundamental é
família escolhida por tanto é que os
amigos da água é família e é com os
amigos também consegue fazer muitas
coisas e muita diferença que temos feito
ao longo dos anos por exemplo deve
contar a história dos meus filhos nunca
teve qualquer intervenção e o homem
nascia amiga nós temos um público entre
83 pipa se um país que talvez a gente tá
volta aqui foi isso também nós vamos nós
lá fui para a seleção do país no fim do
ano era presidente da mesma seção
precisa entrar no trevo de trabalho era
um sucesso com uma companhia das jogadas
o diretor geral do estado definindo os
coaches por não fazer a utilização do
amianto não pra ver se eu estava
frustrado não sabia risco num repente
aparece um dia perguntaram andaram
criada a escola também aqui se fizer de
conseguir fazer a diferença
as instalações sanitárias conseguisse
convencer os amigos que têm empresas
mudaram de escola novas instalações
sanitárias intervenção de nenê
revi área que mudaram as pessoas sérias
e vou tocar se prefere mandar a
acrescentar à segurança à escola em são
mateus também é muito engraçado um
anulado quase um ano e meio dois anos
num almoço com o doutor jorge e com mais
outra me passaria fantástica é
fantástica
vocês produzem plástico a cada cópia de
pessoas através de um corpo e não têm
circulado no país tem 1
isso é uma falha do século passado e já
se diz assim protestou na reserva
daqui um ano vai calar é como no ano
passado são mateus conseguiu retirar o
plástico da sua feira eu vim cá várias
vezes e quando o restaurante seria
garrafas de vidro e queremos um copo que
comprava e quer utilizava noites em
varejo
nós fizemos mais do que isso durante a
faina trouxemos nosso cenário que fez
uma parceria com a câmara de são mateus
e formando seis mil e tal crianças por
lá passaram
um tio de rogi sobre o ambiente sobre a
conservação e também acrescentar valor e
fizemos isto não trazendo mesmo de ter
sido a opção senão todos em lisboa mas
foi mantido suas vizinhas jovens divisão
que fizeram um formação com os nossos
editores e críticos
depois passar esse conhecimento para os
livros tais em oito crianças que
passaram por lá
mais recentemente os incêndios de
monchique e silves monchique é s
foi um evento complicado
vocês aqui também viveram isto uma noite
só com uma grande diferença
acompanhe o país museus pra ajudar o
norte portugal acontece no sul e vi
aquelas coisas todas
neles gols que aconteceu com os remédios
que vieram com nota 1 xíc
ninguém e ainda hoje há famílias que
estão sem nada e foi uma resposta do
estado mais uma vez um dos meus amigos e
um primeiro estava em 150 mil
a nota tem que fazer qualquer coisa e
nós em vez de futebol do norte espanha
fazer uma viagem estava em outubro
estava marcada que fazemos todos os anos
de moto
resolvemos pegar uns amigos e eu voto em
fervença e conseguimos com este grupo e
plataformas do méxico tenta ajudar três
famílias construíram suas casas
esperamos que no verão se estejam lá
está em outra vez e no fundo é isso no
fundo brigando aqui nas palavras do
dólar já resultaram no fundo a evolução
da compaixão e essa é a função da
comparação pode ser feita porque nós não
interessa muito que somos não interessa
muito o título que temos é cadeira nos
sentamos e pouco interessa o que
interessa de fato nós consigamos
inclusão da visa e não precisando ser
conhecido ninguém precisa saber nós nos
veremos que aquela pessoa aquela camila
está melhor porque eu tenho uma conversa
como foi na bem assim e facto é o que
faz a vida valer a pena e que no fundo é
isso que o desafio é cada um de vocês
a revolução da compaixão e tudo
[Aplausos]
[Música]